je suis secrétaire de mairie depuis 58
ans j'ai le secrétaire de la mairie de
Malé creuse j'ai été le secrétaire de 4
ma et vous n'avez jamais eu
d'interruption dans vos fonctions si
j'étais mobilisé pendant la guerre de 14
j'ai repris mes fonctions de secrétaire
de merie quand je suis rentré à la fin
de la guerre et j'ai toujours continué
depuis vous venez d'entrer dans votre
91e année je crois oui dis souvent au
maire au conseiller de me chercher un
remplaçant mais personne n'a voulu me
remplacer je connais tous les villages
toutes les maisons tous les habitants
euh les les personnes qui sont qui
sontés les autres qui sont nécessiteuses
j'ai toujours rempli mon devoir avec
abnégation desvouements des
inéressements je n'ai ni bu ni fumé j'ai
travaillé il est vrai mais le travail
est une la santé bien souvent